there's the idea that to kind of make
great art it has to be painful I just
don't think that's true I love writing
what happens is I just live in the world
you know I went to saltburn and I spent
years there just with all the characters
it's both narratively in character but
it's also kind of texture as well it's
kind of like what do the rooms feel like
are they hot are they cold what does the
grass feel like you're kind of feeling
things very much from a sort of physical
and emotional point of view which is
really how I like to start I try to be
pretty close close to the draft I'm
quite a stickler I had to be really
really care careful about making sure
that every single person really had a
convincing argument because otherwise it
just seems too easy it's much more
interesting if they've really got a good
point you know what I don't like irony
in general you can be Earnest you can
earnestly love things you can be UNS
subtle you can be overwrought you can be
melodramatic and Gothic you can be all
those things we're still very
preoccupied with a certain mode and
method of Storytelling but there's space
in the world for things to be expressed
in all manner of different ways